a novel efforts underway to protect some
of the most famous monkeys in the world
hundreds of Barbary macaques live on the
Gibraltar Peninsula but the animals
roaming free on the British territory at
the southern tip of Spain are under
threat
Jonathan Vigliotti shows us how
conservationists are keeping the peace
between the monkeys and their human
neighbors the jagged Peninsula of
Gibraltar along Spain's
southern coast has been controlled by
the British since the 1700s but high
above this city
where rock meets cloud the monkeys rule
the endangered barbary macaque is the
only wild monkey in Europe and they're
facing off with another set of primates
their human neighbors we're heading to
the top of the rock where the Barbary
monkey lives then we're breakfast is
about to be served
hi every day like clockwork fresh fruit
and vegetables arrived at this remote
peak the impatient jumping right in this
is their territory they're in charge
we're not dr. Eric Shaw leads this
macaque management team who spreads the
spoils
this royal treatment is a peace offering
for this cheeky Bunch
a way of curbing their cravings for
human food how to open your car-door
they know when they wander down in town
and you've left the kitchen window open
they don't want a refrigerator is they
know how to pull the handle open and
help themselves they learn very quickly
so to keep them out of people's
refrigerators you bring the food up here
we are feeding science in and around the
rock but just like children monkeys
prefer sweets he's trying to get into
that both believe it or not he was
trying to unzip me back back this is how
clever they are they know that in
backpacks people carry food he likes you
Barbara cats are professional
pickpockets Oh
everything from backpacks to plastic
bags this petty theft by years of being
illegally fed by visitors at least turn
a blind eye because
gibraltars number one tourist attraction
and while most macaques are friendly
some can be vicious
which is why Shaw's management program
is funded by the government and
supported by the locals but controlling
wild monkeys isn't always easy I can't
send you to texture I don't have a
special whistle if he wants to walk
across the roof he walks across the roof
how many macaques are here on the right
how many Oh 225 on the rock all together
will end when the Apes leave the
religion has it that as long as macaques
live on the rock the British will reign
fight old fetch the devoted these
children have not been evacuated during
world war two when numbers dropped a
superstitious Prime Minister Winston
Churchill even ordered some infra
Morocco
a matter of national security really
this was a Morales this was Britain
this was the Gateway to the
Mediterranean this is the non plus ultra
sand we stand here like the great lion
protecting it to help protect his troop
and people shot gives each monkey a
tracking chip and tattoo along with
annual checkups his latest efforts
including the feedings have helped
reduce conflict
the irony of man feeding animal to keep
them wild is not lost on Shaw who says
as the human population grows
conservation must get creative they're
the last free-ranging primates in the
whole of europe they're on the
endangered species list and if we're not
careful they'll disappear off the face
of the earth how important are these
monkeys here well as long as the monkeys
here here it's gonna be a British rock
that's how important it is according to
legend it's a win-win he says for both
folklore and conservation for CBS this
morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Gibraltar cute
nothing like being attacked by a macaque
on vacation I want to go back there
looks like not can you imagine being bit
by one of those on making to go no I
can't nothing against the monkeys but I
don't want them climbing right you know
my stuff slapping me in the face no
thank you but we're glad they're there